you guys think this is kind of weird you  know New York football teams being good  no I don't think it's weird really  you're on Pace to have your best season  since 2015 when your offense was led by  Ryan Fitzpatrick Chris Ivory and Brandon  Marshall you don't think that's a little  weird no man we're the kings of New York  there's nothing weird about it all right  that's enough no you're not and if  either of you ever use Ryan  Fitzpatrick's name in vain again I will  punch you in the next what's wrong you  don't like us calling ourselves the  kings of New York either of you even  play in New York if you want to fight  over who's the king of New Jersey be my  guest I think your only other  competition is Rutgers you basically  play in Canada what's the difference the  difference is that we don't whatever  we'll see you in the playoffs yeah okay  yeah and we'll see you in the Super Bowl  no you won't no we won't